(Zapoteco) Buenos días a todos,
muchas gracias por hoy estar aquí,
por regalarme su mañana
en un espacio tan bonito.
Buenos días a todos,
muchas gracias por hoy estar aquí,
por regalarme su mañana
en un espacio tan bonito.
Soy hija de una mujer indígena,
de un hombre indígena, a los que
la vida y las circunstancias les negaron
la oportunidad de ir a la escuela.
Mis papás no saben leer,
no saben escribir.
Mi madre tuvo 10 hijos.
A la más grande mi papá la entregó
en matrimonio a los 12 años,
a los 13 años ya era mamá.
A los 31 años mi hermana
Claudia ya tenía 9 hijos.
Pero no responsabilizo
a esa mujer y a ese hombre,
porque en ese entonces
creían que era lo correcto.
Yo vengo de una comunidad
que se llama Quegolani
de los 570 municipios
que tiene mi estado.
Soy indígena, mi lengua
materna es el zapoteco.
Tuve que arrebatar esta lengua
en que hoy me comunico con Uds.
para poder entender
cuáles son mis derechos
y cuáles son mis obligaciones.
Para eso tuve que huir de ese entorno,
con todo el dolor de mi corazón,
ese día, hace más de 25 años,
mi corazón se dividió en dos:
uno se quedó allá en la montaña
a 7 horas de la capital de mi estado,
donde está mi historia,
mi esencia, mi raíz,
mi lengua, mi vestimenta;
y la otra está conmigo.
Para poder entender primero
por qué mis ojos no entendían
o por qué no me gustaba lo que yo veía.
¿Por qué mi madre era
la primera en levantarse
y era la última en dormirse?
¿Por qué tenía yo que levantarme con ella?
Tuve que aprender a hacer tortilla,
a traerle leña en el burro,
porque eso es lo que teníamos
que hacer las mujeres.
Yo no quise eso y para eso
cuando yo salí de mi tierra...
no había luz, no había carretera;
yo me dormía en piso de tierra.
Si me hubieran dicho que dormir
en cama estaba más chingón,
pues lo hubiera escogido ¿no?
Pero para poder entender eso,
tuve que arrebatar algo que
yo creo que es la herramienta
para poder transformar
mucho de lo que nos duele
que es la educación.
Tuve que arrebatar mi educación
porque la vida no me la regaló.
Tuve que trabajar en la mañana
y en la tarde estudiar
mi secundaria y bachillerato.
Soy contadora pública.
Al paso del tiempo
yo regresaba a mi entorno
y mi mamá seguía levantándose
a las 3 de la mañana,
a hacer tortilla, la cal carcome,
porque desde un día antes,
tienes que cocer el nixtamal
quebrajar el nixtamal,
poner tres tortillas
en el comal porque luego dicen
que no somos mujeres ¿no?
Pero no responsabilizo a ese entorno.
Responsabilizo a la circunstancia,
que es la pobreza y la marginación.
y no la pobreza y la marginación
de aquí, sino la de aquí.
Porque cuando una mente no está educada,
tiene miedo a cuestionar,
tiene miedo a exigir pero, sobre todo,
tiene miedo de decidir
cómo quiere las cosas.
Pero cuando una mente se educa,
descubres qué es la libertad;
descubres cuáles son
tus derechos y tus obligaciones,
sin negar tus raíces, yo me siento
orgullosa de ser indígena,
de hablar mi lengua,
de ir a mi pueblo a hacer la fiesta.
Pero eso no significa que sea menos,
no significa que mi comunidad
o que los 16 millones de mexicanas
y mexicanos que habitan este país,
que son indígenas, no tengan
derecho a educación, a salud.
Pero entendí algo,
que nadie iba a cambiar eso
si yo no daba el primer paso.
Que es precisamente romper
ese paradigma cultural
que la propia sociedad a veces nos impone.
Porque, de repente, decir indígena
es como ver el museo andante
y no, no somos museos andantes,
somos personas capaces de opinar
y de decidir por nosotros.
Cuando termino mi carrera,
porque lo tuve que arrebatar
trabajando, vendiendo
lo que fuera en la calle,
y no me arrepiento, gracias
a eso descubrí mi libertad.
Fui instructora comunitaria
y de ahí quería yo ser doctora,
pero pues no había cómo
y por eso terminé siendo contadora
por eso hoy sé que 1 + 1 es 2:
derechos y obligaciones.
Cuando regresaba [a mi comunidad]
yo no entendía
por qué las mujeres regresaban
con las manos vacías.
La respuesta era "eres mujer,
primero consíguete un marido
y después a ver si te toca".
Pero si en la escuela me decían
que había un artículo de
la Constitución de mi país
que decía que todos somos iguales,
y resultaba que ahí no.
Que el uso y costumbre
impedía ese derecho.
Vuelvo a repetir: no responsabilizo
a esos hombres y mujeres
porque la mayoría de ellos ni siquiera
saben qué es derechos humanos
ni siquiera saben qué es obligación.
Pero cuando entendí eso,
empecé a ir a la cancha del pueblo
a jugar,
pues me convertí en la loca.
Ir a la misa, estaba yo loca.
Pero asumí esa responsabilidad
porque nadie lo iba a hacer por mí.
Empezando por mí.
De ahí, por mi familia,
de ahí por mi comunidad,
por mi estado, también para
ser visible para este país.
Que soy una persona capaz de
decidir por lo que yo quiero.
De ahí quise ser presidenta de mi pueblo.
Pero pues ya sabrán, el uso y costumbre
me impidió ese derecho.
Pero eso no fue lo grave.
Lo grave fueron las respuestas que
me dieron las instancias gubernamentales.
Que era el uso y costumbre
de la comunidad,
que era la autonomía de mi comunidad,
que era un derecho consuetudinario,
que no había una ley que me protegiera.
En pleno siglo XXI, en 2007.
No la respuesta que
me dieron en mi pueblo,
sino la respuesta que me daban
las instancias de gobierno,
era lo que más me dolía.
No porque quisiese ser presidenta,
sino porque era la puerta para poder ser
visible desde nuestra propia comunidad,
porque para partidos
políticos sí votábamos,
porque teníamos una credencial.
Pero para lo más importante
que era ser visibles
para nuestra familia, para nuestra
comunidad, era el uso y costumbre.
No me quedé ahí, empecé a denunciar
y hoy gracias a eso,
ingresé a la política.
Hoy que tan cuestionada está la política,
asumí esa responsabilidad,
porque hoy a todos nos meten
en un solo costal,
y no.
Yo creo que la política
tiene que servir para que la ciudadanía
empiece a cambiar lo que no nos gusta.
Porque es un camino menos doloroso
para llegar a cambiar lo que nos duele.
Por eso ingresé a la política,
para cambiar la respuesta
que me dieron en su momento,
¿Y dónde estaba? Ahí adentro,
cambiar la constitución de mi estado,
para que nunca más le dijeran a una mujer,
no a mí, mal que bien,
yo ya soy o ya era contadora.
Sino que era para ellas.
Para esas mujeres invisibles.
Para esas mujeres que ni siquiera
les preguntan si quieren tener 10 hijos.
No es malo tener 10, 5 o 4 hijos,
siempre y cuando nosotras lo decidamos.
Era la puerta que yo encontré
para que hoy en mi pueblo,
las mujeres puedan ejercer su derecho.
Hoy en mi pueblo ya votan las mujeres.
Hoy en mi pueblo ya hay tres mujeres
integrando el cabildo municipal.
De los 570 municipios de mi estado,
417 se rigen bajo el sistema
de usos y costumbres.
De las 68 etnias que hay en este país,
16 están en mi estado.
Estoy buscando que nadie
nos diga que por nuestra cultura
no podamos acceder al desarrollo,
no podamos opinar
cómo queremos cambiar
nuestras historias y nuestras cosas.
No, sino que sea una herramienta
que nos ayude a decir:
"Este es México, esto es
nuestro color, nuestro sabor".
Y eso lo adquirí con la educación.
Y, a través de la educación,
encontré la palabra libertad.
Hoy para mí la libertad es lo más sagrado.
Gracias a eso fui diputada federal y dije:
"No solamente en mi estado, también
para esos 16 millones de mexicanas
que habitan en este país, a nadie
le digan que no tienen derecho".
En 2014 logré una reforma
a la constitución de mi país,
para que nadie me dijera o le den
la respuesta que me dieron en su momento.
No solo eso, en el mismo
2014 la ONU adopta esa reforma
para que en todo el mundo
en donde hay población indígena,
los jefes de estado estén obligados
a cambiar esas prácticas
en donde todavía se violenta
el desarrollo de nuestras comunidades.
Porque todo el mundo
nos habla de democracia,
y yo he dicho: "La democracia
la considero como una paloma,
un ala de mujer y otra de hombre,
sin la otra ala no podemos
llegar a esa democracia,
y más con el rostro indígena.
Hoy agradezco que está la persona
más importante también conmigo,
que es mi hijo, otra razón
por la que no voy a dejarme,
sino que voy a seguir, porque no basta
que se haya logrado esta reforma,
ahora es pedir que se aplique
para que no esté solo en una reforma
sino que sea de verdad que
de los 417 municipios,
mínimo haya 5 mujeres o 20 mujeres
siendo presidentas municipales.
Vuelvo a repetir: lo importante
no es votar y ser votadas,
lo importante es que vamos a ser
visibles para el resto de este México
(Zapoteco) Hoy entiendo la libertad
como ese humo que corre por la ladera
del cerro de mi pueblo.
Muchas gracias.
Hoy entiendo la libertad como ese humo
que corre por la ladera
del cerro de mi pueblo.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)